when you look forward uh one of the
things i'm personally interested in is
can el salvador essentially embrace
bitcoin and potentially move from a
developing nation to a developed nation
can it launch itself forward and kind of
move up in the world order if you will
how do you see bitcoin impacting the
country uh economically and socially uh
over the next you know 20 25 years is
something that you're you're ultra
bullish on or how do you view this
no super bullish i mean people
people overestimate what can happen in a
year but they underestimate what can
happen in 10 years and so i think the
changes are going to be slow there's
going to be jobs i mean we're already
seeing dozens of companies coming in
opening up legal entities hiring people
that are paying significantly above the
local wages and so you're going to have
this influx not just of better paying
jobs but opportunity for people to
increase their skills and that's also
going to drive the
people into furthering their education
because that's been a big challenge here
people like well why would i go to
university if there's not going to be a
job waiting for me at the end and so i
think
10 years from now it'll be shocking the
difference that we see in el salvador
that the majority of the people will be
going to university that the majority of
the people will um not be working in
corn fields but they'll be working in
the tech sector they'll be working in
the finance sector and el salvador will
really be like a regional hub and leader
you know similar to like a singapore
yeah and when you start to think about
how important maybe let's start with the
country's youth is right um it seems to
me that the bitcoin as an asset could be
hyper bullish for a country but you need
the people to participate as well what
has your experience been with the young
people you described a little bit
earlier that they immediately got
currency that wasn't backed by a country
and they seemed much more receptive to
it is it something where you see them
just using it are they excited about it
as a savings technology are they out
kind of educating their friends and and
talking to people like what what do they
seem to be doing because to me they are
the future of the country right
no they definitely are excited about it
i mean of course like anybody their
emotions kind of go up and down with the
price fluctuations and so you know when
we were looking back in january and
february everybody was ultra bullish and
you know super excited uh you know then
we went into kind of the downturn and
and people were a little more hesitant
about things actually we hardly saw
anybody sell most of them held through
that
and so that was kind of really
encouraging to see but yeah they are
excited not just about the the fact that
it can go up in value but the fact that
it connects them to the broader world
for the first time they feel like proud
to be here in el salvador that they're
not 10 years behind the rest of the
world they're actually 10 years ahead of
the rest of the world
and so they are leading this
and i don't think you can underestimate
the impact that that has on people just
that hope and that motivation that there
is a future here and they can be part of
it
yeah one of the pieces
that i think folks need to be careful of
is obviously
salvadorians
have great pride in their country
and i think that they're very interested
from the folks that i've talked with in
building a better future
for their country but obviously bitcoin
is from around the world both in america
and elsewhere uh seem to be attracted to
the country now some of that is through
the economic incentives some of that is
just wanting to be around and surrounded
by uh like-minded individuals and so
there's a lot of tourists or
international travelers that keep going
there any thoughts on
how helpful those people from outside
the country can be
are there risks to too many you know
kind of non-salvadorians coming is there
resentment at all or maybe there's
positive reception like how do you just
think about the local citizens versus
those that are coming there because of
bitcoin
i think it's definitely mixed i mean
we've seen a lot of people here come
here for self-serving purposes they're
just trying to ride the
wave of publicity about el salvador and
tie themselves to it and you know a lot
of them with projects that i would view
as scams and so you know we're
definitely concerned about that but in
general i've been very impressed the
number of you know large companies that
have come in here and have expressed
this view of you know el salvador is a
small country we don't assume you know
we don't expect to make money here but
we just really want to support what's
going on and be part of it in some way
and so we're willing to invest even if
it doesn't pay dividends here we feel
like as far as for the overall
um infrastructure of bitcoin and for the
future of bitcoin that is super
important and so yeah we definitely
encourage people to come to el salvador
but not with a a view that you're going
to teach the people here something with
the view that you're going to learn from
them like how are people really using
bitcoin in real transactional ways these
people here that are living in a tin
shack with a dirt floor are doing you
know hundreds of bitcoin transactions a
year which is you know dwarfs what even
some of the biggest bitcoiners in the us
are doing so they really understand the
logistical problems they understand the
infrastructure problems with with
internet connectivity and those sorts of
things
and they can really
teach the bitcoin companies how to build
products that can go out to bigger
developing countries like india or or
all throughout africa and so i think
they can really use um el salvador as as
a learning center for what will work and
that will also benefit el salvador
because it just brings in all these
high-paying jobs and and provides um
a environment where locals can start
bitcoin businesses that can thrive
what is your message or kind of guidance
for those that can't travel to el
salvador so plenty of people kind of
internationally are very interested
they're watching this is there anything
they can do to help or kind of further
uh the development of this
yeah so we we often will post things
with projects that we're trying to raise
funds to support you know the education
of locals for them to go to university
or things like that we have a number of
projects for the bitcoin beach project
that that we're always open to people
helping financially support
but i think also just to kind of keep
following it and to have an open mind
and to not jump to conclusions if we
have like a bad month or we hit a
roadblock you know this is going to be a
long term game and so i think we need to
be in this for the long haul what's up
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're going to be the best business show
we obviously need the best partner
that's why the exclusive sponsor the
best business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]